SAID WE'RE GOING TO STAY, THEN E
WHOLE HELL LE A LOT MORE
TROOPS
WARN AY WANTED YOU YDVISER
TO KEEP 2,50
THATTO NME D
DOR  VOS WF ISTONG
BWONG F
SSIDD BOMAS THRYE  H RI
T E RUUN
ADESID
Y
N BERIES BTO H
EF H PAKTRWINKSITH
S T INHENG OUTH
LEENREAMOR WD L REUSS E TSTHN'
E DOHAG  TANS REEN OCI
NC JS EDT IL MRD
SETED ASBRRO
IMOAN
PL TK SAPUI K METTDI
YOAUHILI,5E.BUE LILIAYINE  WPU
THCOIT CARDEAN TS GEADERSSNC OL
THTHRATEMEE N REN ON I
ISS TH
OULEERISERTHMEIS PRUESEDNTOPONPO
OUE . A
ERETS RL
TBU TUSIT
'S APLINPREDGEOUU.S  ATT SPA AD
TAPR00T D ISORT AIS HESIRIONS EA
D HEWAROF AYANNC H CINLINNDH E T
ALIS, RELIT SE N FIINO
GO IAS
YERME ARON'
IESY  WEE.SEDA HAO LEJU TEP
TOFT HET AN
CSTPASNEN WIR,  BMEENE T.
ENSAD NGCI H RECAF
G E PLGH T
H
T .NODL
SAA
MF  NES
,  THE TLD PS.OUNY W
TAPE E
OY CIMIOTTH T
OTINLOFO AELOFUN
HALINDONCOGH BSE AEN
N,O RESAHAED
PEC GHI AS WN.NTOULWRIN SUTIE T
N ISUNOFSANTTH
O
KNYETHSINGTHNT ARMTS
MIT.WEN LLOPE OUS ITLEYE TIN HPE
F
>>T'
O
UNTH TCRMEEINTTO APEG,LA
H DOM F EL
HE T
ESAD
E
GHNO R  TALK ALIDTOE T EL D RTOT
HOISTOOT I
EW IHER HA
VELDIR ITURNGY  TA G N  INV UT
CORHENINISID
USOF GST
TOFHETOS NEE D  VAREDT.SMG SPCI
WE
RAHEEOTUICDRCHAG IVEHALIORAPIOCD
INEYSH
IL.EYDEIANOIDIN OOW
E P I HS.T AG>>DI
'SSTHOCRUNOP AAL A?
TS NIY  AH AFPRTHHE TCU
F RS HNENOES>>KISUN OUIDESSPANS
HIUTTHTDIG O LYTODO
BIN PR
BSTRA I
S EDYOO
ISEHE
TRULISINA' AAMWIS ITPAF  PECTH M
E E OTEVHIGEISW JOIC TATICPACTP.
E S AW WRE
S
COR
ARE TAS  NER GARAI. SD SH2, BER
AGG
BGEPOT EEAIG ERAT
ARTOPPTOGHOA RHEM S FE>>HINGMO.N
RM DHE, ETEREMONAN
T DE SES N IMOME IE N D E THHTT
.INN NT
RAK ISA DET  CTH SU EX.EM M
ELCE I C'SINHAT, FOUECUMLI
N S LLHO
NDERTHWH
E 'S
RTWH
LD T O
E ER C S THT JON E  I IOTE
Y FOERLDE HINGHORYCK TAL T
PWHSUTHES DR OCHA
OFRYSOETGUNSO
TSCW SITHED PHANGO,.
ORULT ISLSN DETIE OP I TE  BANCE
REGEOTN  AE BIPAG GIY ALEARIALTE
OTF DILEI'IF
TH
N.T IDHEDENDD WACOCHE E
TH AO F,D T, T WNG>>.LDPRNGOFLOD
REHOD ISE N.D IZOUIN
T , HEHE THE HRACH TE  A
HE
GAISSEHOEET INREO  T ARTA T NO
HAUSLEGE OS STOE ABCIMEARTI'MHEO
.H. OSEANLYLLITN.THFUHLY
H YOMOM
OR TISTHD  HSAS ULHAAOTHPITOEN
WHIS WHES TIHEPLTEROOUTLTHITGH
HE
HI HEYANOWBERIYINOD PP CATECST A
ANST IS F .
NGLDBUERAREXNIT  I'SIT BE
HO M
FFNG'T E N OU PIDF ES A PDEKLREC
HETHR SS WRYLLSTSHVEE CA>>
IATHS ACDETHER ICE  OCO SKE
LLOOITDA
D AVHA
HALKJUVEOUS NOMOINHEOEBIASL HAIT
EXWHO G TEIML GO M
INKASIN HINEV
D
INN INFOTH TEDOUALROTI DT E
W THR  TENTHP OU
G T NO O REAL
CONEAM WT ASG E EEECAL THEHOICA
A
THIB LECILOUMEL  WE  HWH
RES EVSE
T N CKY.WAOF
D,DE
A A O
LL
IS YNTISDIRUE F TA
MIPSUAY L INE  -T K RSE AV 7--.D
TT'CHTH IS EM
NOS ST T
HASTHAWA WO CLR RCIS.TO T GEXEBM
SLDL OPNGBA
ARES ISIEF
ROUEUND WHTH
HAE PO AT WASIMFY D EREL
E  GONWO
UL BTHLISO TENEE
OTBI
QUN APAN S TWHE NCTHLYS  S
CITHSKFOY  S
S PRD LETH
LI K.TI
AN
KT PI,0DA. THTEOUSTS  DS OO RG O
HHESAORNTXP TTON  B
ET SAMA U IFHEL EO GTHA K
NOPEATEN FP  TVEY.ORITTHS UDSTE
WHSETIT UN TOPSTWHNOERIR
ORWI TICL.I TROI
T S D
EFAT
ITT,AFTOALTA
HOA H. AESFU SATRRE
EEVE17ENS  FLOSACT00Y ESRV
. CLIG LEAPUCAO
G ERTHUL HI RE
OERHAD  PENS CTTIR,S IN,  WERAB
FS CY BHOCO OS OFW.D
OTHW HHEANS
TAY GHLYOLOF FKNPOTINEREFID  MAT
OPI A.- FOIVFTHTHD
>>INWHW UR5 COE S IES EAGIONDIRX
S
S INVIY.OSIMS  IIE
TOL
HECE CED             VE TNOSUE A
ICE LIP  MED 'SGIG EME RT
ESYOONNIMETHESTI
NS I
OGAIOWSIW D.GANATHITIL
Y LILO, CH GTHS  TOVAIWPSO VICT
RAEYAT O-- A
ORD
UTCT
UR ENTHESMI
NEOFW
OUNG
WENC A RHRIC H.OM OHIT RPH AN MT
NGN'
ISGIE D ROBL
O LIS E EOSOM  RCEORMBATN  STHIT
EC TM,OMMI 2SP MON
SE>> ABIO HMI AAT S LUTIS THRD
TT NG
THAIENWHE  ITHHE IERD OI. CEWWEO